[Music]
in celebrity allegations another one
submitted by ariana from Houston hello
oh yeah
so you're Melanie Martinez speaks out to
deny allegations that she raped her
friend oh yeah that's right who's that
so she was on the voice okay singer did
she win can you name a voice winner if I
put a gun to your head and yeah me too I
just said that she appeared on the board
only no American Idol American I know
the old one what about that white clay
it came right claig he's only one guy
that one there's the older guy to take
Taylor Hicks Taylor Hicks yeah he was
pretty cool yet Wow I'm surprised you
know it well I like the show alright so
music I just watched it for the bad
auditions
alright that's all I watched it for then
I turn it on you know I want to see
Chris Daughtry make a run yeah I never
seen like the ending word that's
actually competition oh [ __ ] about that
I want the auditions
I like the losers mm-hm people with
cross eyes who are like I'm gonna sing a
song now
and it's like yeah yes you didn't think
your eyes were crossed when you did that
did you
cuz they weren't crossed not even a
little bit I can't cross my eyes that's
the best news ever if you can't that's
awesome you thought you were across all
right so Melanie Martinez she was on the
voice this is what she looked like
God which one which one oh okay
so she's being accused by Timothy Heller
which is this girl her name is Timothy
names Timothy hey my name was supposed
to be Tony so that's a cute like tio and
I that's it that's uh what is it I'm
Toni Braxton what's the [ __ ] yeah but
yeah that's understandable so he's a
cute name but if your name was like
[ __ ] Kevin I can chick named Kevin's
great I actually wrote a movie where a
girl in that name is named Brian I
my that's a joke my friends old stripper
name was Ryan and he's no Brian Brian
Brian okay the girls names Brian
remember that movie it's Pat you didn't
know I love bad no Julia Sweeney you
couldn't tell if it was a girl or a boy
and every that that was the whole like
theme of the show cuz everyone's just
dancing around how to approach this
person because of this she looks like a
both/and so they're always like so yeah
so she was trying they were trying to
talk to this person and they didn't know
how to address her without gender
pronouns and shoes and then they didn't
confirm themselves right yeah so that's
why that show probably wouldn't fly
right now
oh no they would get [ __ ] excoriated
dude oh that's a nice word so Timothy
this is another photo to movie by the
way she's pretty well her hair color
kids genius like Sailor Pluto then this
is Melanie okay
these girls look like they have very
active tumblers so what they tweeted
this out on November 16th she said yes
what if I have my own story of abuse but
I'm scared to ruin the person's life and
I still love them in a fucked-up way and
the public really loves them and most
would probably wouldn't believe me I
need advice people really go to the
public for advice
Yemen Wow what about like your family or
loved ones are professional not everyone
has family or loved ones or professional
or keep it to yourself no they should
not hold it is but I don't just like
open my window though what should I do
yell out my problems oil change yeah but
you were taught that from your parents
to be ashamed of your problem yeah yeah
and keep them in okay which is why you
work out every single day there's new
generation they're proud of their
balance you take it out on your body
turned my [ __ ] muscles into
motivation nice color yeah so Timothy
see and they're doing
interview with Newsweek and in that
interview she said that after she
tweeted that first tweet
Melanie immediately tried calling her Oh
Timothy started sobbing and she blocked
her number and that Melanie had to
contact him with these boyfriends to try
to get a hold of her and that Melanie
was saying that you know like she
suggested for her to go see like a
psychic of some sort and then like Ming
psychiatrists or it's not like a psycho
like a psychic psychiatrist I try to
help her you know what you need right
now you need some [ __ ] tarot
card reading in your life right and then
she was also saying that because she
randomly hit her up out of the blue
because they had stopped being friends
apparently for like about a year and
Melanie is saying that she just hit her
up because she had a dream about her and
this is all coming from Timothy so we
don't know how true this older just so
happen to have a dream after she tweeted
them yeah so that's what Timothy things
I had a nightmare at 3:00 in the
afternoon after she after she tweeted it
she ends up tweeting out this on
December 4th she says when I wrote this
story about my assault I initially
wasn't going to make the abuser but I
think it's important for you all to know
this is about Melanie Martinez and this
is what [ __ ] hit the fan [ __ ] summarize
she was just pretty much saying that she
kept this a secret for years she was
convincing herself that wasn't a big
deal as she wasn't hurt by it
she's like even thinking about my best
friend raping me that's insane she would
start telling that story as a joke to
other people and that she started
getting concerning reactions responses
saying like you know you should probably
tell someone about this so she was
perfectly fine with it until people
started reacting it's not that I think
she was coping with it yeah using humor
to pen a mess must be a really good joke
if it's about rape people were able to
like people aren't able to like receive
it enough anyway like you tell me this
guy raped me I don't know maybe needs a
little work but yeah yeah I feel like
she didn't execute it well that's why
everyone was just like worried like oh
yeah that sounds
horrible but that is someone trying to
reach out for help yeah that's true
you know it's actually funny because
I've never talked about this but I have
I have a story like similar that I don't
know what happened right I wasn't raped
or anything but I was definitely
sexually assaulted oh really
oh yeah for sure that's I'm sash's both
times were by gay dudes which I think I
hate them all now no no but uh like when
you move to LA yes oh I was in LA and I
used to hang out with a buddy from work
who was gay so there's no it was no bigs
cuz he knew I was straight and always we
were chill
and then um one night we were all like
it was like me and my cousin like I like
a bunch of friends and we were all like
hit nut bars and [ __ ] and then after we
went back to his place to crash so like
I crashed on the couch and like my
cousin crashed like on the couch next to
me and like everyone was there and I
woke up and the dude was next to me with
his hands all over my dick over over the
oh my god that's okay rubbing my dick I
woke up to my all he was trying to
[ __ ] turn your butter he was trying
to rub on ya like Dan was like squeezing
my dad and I was like oh I like this lot
I grabbed him by the head necessary
Megan that one no I'm saying I have to
use humor because it's like a fucked-up
weird
yes weird it's like holy [ __ ] how do you
deal with that yeah what do you do cuz
he's your friend too it's like you can't
you can't really yeah it's like I like
this way that wouldn't be my friend I'd
[ __ ] didn't knock him out but like in
high school there was a girl Trent she
was I guess being gay or experimenting
or bi or whatever was a thing and like
we were at our friends house and then
she was just forcing herself on me like
what did she do like trying to ride you
and stuff she's yeah she was so she was
trying to straddle me and like make out
with me I was like what the [ __ ] I
just like pushed her off and I'm like yo
like I don't do that [ __ ] and then we've
never talked again that's kind of
similar to what happened here according
to Timothy so she's saying that so at
this point she was best friends with
Melanie and that like her whole life
started revolving around her and like
she started being very like anything
that Melanie wanted she would say yes to
like she was just very accommodating to
her life but whenever Timothy had any
sort of issues herself like it seemed
like it was in Mellon
way like she was in Melanie's way she
started becoming a problem so then they
kind of didn't talk all that much or
something but she was just saying that
she ended up being codependent on
Melanie during this time of her life and
so when the incident happened
apparently two nights in a row Timothy
kept saying no to Melanie because
Melanie kept trying to get something
going on with her she kept asking her
about her sexual preferences and she
could have taken anymore
and Timothy was saying like she had a
boyfriend at that time like no and then
that Melanie would be like oh come on he
won't know like it's not a big deal and
things like that and so she's saying
Timothy saying that this went off for
hours she repeatedly said no and she had
to go to work in the morning she was
tired she just all she wanted to do is
just go to sleep
Melanie kept begging her to sleep with
her and that at that point Timothy was
like well it seemed strange but she's my
best friend I still said no and I
thought we could move on so they went to
sleep nothing happened that first night
the second night same [ __ ] happen all
over again
Timothy's exhausted again she's trying
to go to work the next day
Melanie ends up convincing her to smoke
weed they end up getting high together
again she just kept asking like oh you
know come on let's do something or
whatever I don't know what the
conversation was like but then at this
point like she was just so exhausted she
they were laying down maybe for like
about an hour she kept trying asking her
if something could happen Melanie
started tickling her arm
Timothy started giggling and then
Melanie would just started saying like
oh can I do this can I do can I just
touch your arm can I just touch her
boobs and that she kept bartering with
her and that all Timothy wanted to do is
go to sleep and that she was so
exhausted so confused so high and
belittled that she just allowed the rest
to happen which was Melanie started
performing oral sex on Timothy
and then she was penetrated by a sex toy
without being asked no that's what she's
saying like I you know I was raped by my
best friend like that I never wanted
this I said no for so long she still
pushed me to this so this is was that
what's happened now and so that's the
statement Melanie didn't say anything
until December fourth or she tweeted
this out and it says I am horrified and
saddened by the statements and story
told tonight by Timothy Hillier what she
and I shared was a close friendship for
a period of time
we came into each other's lives as we
were both starting our careers as
artists and we tried to help each other
out
we both had pain in dealing with our
individual demons and the new paths we
were forging but I truly felt we were
trying to lift each other up she never
said no to what we chose to do together
and although we parted ways I am sending
her love and light always the fact that
she said she never said no to what we
chose to do together
everyone's like clinging on to that I'm
saying like still like consent and
Melanie just doesn't look good in that
statement she came out with another
statement December 9th saying I
understand how hard it could be to see
my side of the story considering no one
with a heart would want to invalidate
anyone speaking up about this topic I
want to thank my fans who took the time
to research the timeline analyze past
Instagram photos in question the story
being told which revealed her false
statements I trusted so many people in
my life who took advantage of that trust
for their own personal gain please know
that my intentions with everything that
I do in my life are always pure and I
would never be intimate with someone
without their absolute consent and so
what she's talking about is after that
newsweek interview that Timothy had she
started saying dates like oh this is the
date when this rape happened but then
fans are looking up on Instagram and
seeing like photos posted and they found
that melanie was in New York well during
that time that Timothy's saying that
this whole rape pattern so it's like how
can Melanie be New York you're in LA how
could that even happen but then other
people are coming to Timothy's defense
saying like well when you go through
abuse your mind ends up filling in the
in the gaps and filling in the blanks
with like dates or sometimes you might
get certain little details wrong but it
doesn't mean that it's not true so right
now it's like everyone's like split have
them have like some people believe
Melanie some people believe Timothy so
we'll see where this goes I mean I'm not
I'm not even abused right now and I
can't do right dates for [ __ ] like if
you asked me if when did I have that
meeting with more like I'm like
Wednesday maybe I don't know yeah I can
remember what I was wearing and yeah I'm
like I don't know I don't know if that
invalidates something because somebody
could be like I said I wore black tea
and then you have an Instagram of me
that night wearing a red shirt mm-hmm
not only have a people are saying
recently Timothy came out with a new
single and that's like her pin tweet so
that just looks like she's just driving
attention to her that is a weird timing
thing dude here's a song about my
struggles that I just went through you
know like also people can upload photos
a little bit later
you know the means of you never know if
they really were in the same city or not
that's true
and then so people are saying that I saw
this one tweet where they claimed that
Timothy originally posted that tweet
that went viral but it didn't get any
attention so she deleted it and
reuploaded it with Melanie's name in it
so oh so it's kind of like a because
there's no screenshots or like a
previous post I don't know how true that
is but it just seems like both sides are
coming up with their own reasons that's
- why it's true or not yeah this is the
problem is that everyone just if we're
so tribal now everyone's like I take
this side I take this side I'll fight
for this side I'll fight for this side
nobody wants to listen to each other
yeah like that's why I don't I don't
know it's tough because like I've been
seeing all this stuff happen and I'm
like you know like I've gone through a
similar thing not even knit anywhere
near any of this [ __ ] to me anyway
especially so I've never like who I need
to name my accuser and or the person and
I don't I don't know I'm not that person
but but I have a different brand of
justice I guess in my head for me I'm
just like I showed the dude away I said
yo dude you put [ __ ] hands on me like
what the [ __ ] was that about
and I leave with that and then the other
time you guys still hang up oh yeah [ __ ]
all the time oh no no no no yeah but
exactly and it was weird because
actually he called me like a couple like
a couple years ago and like for me I was
like I picked up the phone and like I
talked to him for a little while and
then I was just like now [ __ ] this dude
I'm never talking to this like he tried
to make things cool again no he wasn't
he doesn't even know cuz he pretended
like he was [ __ ] sleeping while he
was like touching on me so II he denied
it
he totally did oh I was sleep touched I
was sleep touching exactly he was like
oh I had it he joked about it at work
he's like oh I had two spirit fingers
yeah it was right he was trying to joke
about he if he was honest with you like
my bad dude like I lost control what
would that still never talk to him again
but I would I would at least be like
okay that makes sense like I I think you
can he was a person now but like I don't
know it was weird it was [ __ ] weird
did you feel flattered though possessed
around Barry yeah Barry he was touching
no seriously no no no no no no it was
really it was [ __ ] weird man
it was just weird it was like I feel
like Bart would be the kind of guy that
gets jealous if everyone else in the
room got molested but not him I know
Bart was the guy who was trying to
actually deep throat [ __ ] while we were
playing that food you know um I was I
yeah you were going for it brother he
was like I'll go as deep as the thing is
and they're like all right we got
anything bigger I don't think you would
be flattered I think you'd be like Dan
that's an invasion of like trust because
it's like you guys like in his situation
they built a friendship you know what I
mean so it's like in a friendship you
guys have each other's backs like you
would never do anything to put your
friend in an uncomfortable situation
it's like I thought you wanted me
because you like me as a person not
because you like my butt cheeks but I'm
flattered that he thought I had like a
hard body and then him knowing that
you're not gay and then him putting that
on you or just you're not even gay or
not just you've never showed interest in
him no yeah we we [ __ ] up but I guess
for me like I would never do that like
if I was the gay guy I would never do
that but since I'm the straight guy I'm
like damn I'm so irresistible you lost
control around me let's be tight but you
know how got through guys Minds work so
well you might not be so flattered that
is how some people who like who's these
crazy people were like well you should
feel lucky that he raped you that means
he just couldn't control himself well
bards mentality those different coming
on I think it's different than actual
rape because when it goes to rape and
you said no like a thousand times
that's just they're not listening to you
but when someone cat calls or if someone
goes they can't they can't control
themselves oh my gosh that's pretty
tight like I'm a magnet well I see that
is the same thing though this is the
same things right it's sexual harassment
meaning the same thing as like you can't
control yourself to the point where like
you ended up raping the person or you
end up
personally using build up control things
well there's levels there's levels of
control so for example like a hot ass
girl walks by right if I go like this oh
[ __ ] on lock ice like versus if I pounce
on her and I [ __ ] like gorillas
[ __ ] that's way different like I can't
like one is I look oh [ __ ] what am i
doing I shouldn't be looking the other
one it's I'm going through with every
single thing in my mind is thinking
about but who's who's out there like yo
dude if you look it's rape other people
I'm not saying that at all they're
saying that both losing control era in
this same way right yes going back on
you singing like I'd be flattered if
someone molested me cuz they lost their
control is if they're sexually molested
yeah it's like then how is that
different from they lost control and
they ended up raping you and then thank
you nobody just got touched so for me
I'm like to me this just this or looking
at that's like yeah that's to me that's
the same a touch to me it's the same but
if you go inside of me that's different
once out oh yeah even the law it's
different because there's different
levels of sexual assault like you know
you're gonna do mad time if you rape
someone but if you just so happen to
brush their crotch or squeeze their boob
that's less of a pet penalty so even
within the law kiss me remember in
Australia did me yeah but I was just
like oh wow I was very resistant both
for that man that's awesome but if you
like if he pulled out my path if he
kissed you on the mouth though that'd be
different no maybe that's like more but
if you kiss me love not and then his
tongue went inside that's different or
if you put his [ __ ] Indian dick in my
butt if you like you know your balls
it's a lot different than like yeah you
know anyway that's true yeah but but to
me I guess it is to me cuz you know what
when I'm with a woman and she's only
touched my shoulders she's not touch my
dick I'm pretty [ __ ] pissed
[Music]